recently I was recommended a video
called how much Fang pay software
engineers in 2022 now we all know that
Fang software engineers make a fat
salary so I went into the video
expecting 200 to 300 000 but I was blown
away by how much these guys actually
make take Facebook for example in an
entry-level software engineer themselves
nearly crosses two hundred thousand
dollars per year with just two
promotions this nearly doubles to four
hundred thousand dollars per year and
we're only halfway through the ranks if
you make it to level seven you'd be
making nearly a million dollars per year
and if you make it all the way to level
8 which is principal engineer you'd be
making a 1.6 million dollars per year a
very similar pay scale can be found at
Google and most other Silicon Valley
companies as well now let's be clear
here we're not talking about VPS or
c-suite Executives we're talking about
high-ranking coders like it directors
and they're pulling in seven figures for
perspective there are literally CEOs of
everyday brands that make a comparable
amount dish CEO Eric Carlson for example
made it 2.9 Million Dollars last year
and he's literally the CEO if we take a
look at lower ranking c-suite Executives
many of them actually make less than
these Fang software Engineers Stuart a
levy for example is the CFO of Domino's
Pizza and he only made a 1.57 million
dollars last year also we shouldn't note
that Domino's Pizza was literally the
second the fastest growing stock of the
2010s only beaten up by Netflix so these
Executives beat Facebook Apple Amazon
Google and the rest of the Fortune 500
in terms of stock growth for an entire
decade yet their compensation is
literally lower than principal engineers
at Fame either the executives at the
second tier companies are getting ripped
off or Fang is just flexing historically
the most straightforward way to become
rich at young Gauger without starting a
business was to grind out your 20s at an
investment bank or a hedge fund but it
looks like Fang has completely thrown
that out the window with their
compensation packages for a highly
ambitious individual who is recruited
straight out of college or even without
College two promotions at Fang seems
pretty reasonable within 10 years
meaning that they could be earning
nearly four hundred thousand dollars in
their 30s and here's the cool thing
that's the 2022 salary by the time you
actually spend it 10 years in the
industry this salary would probably be
closer to five hundred thousand dollars
per year if not more and even if you
only get one promotion after that you'd
probably be making close to seven
figures if not seven figures in other
words if you become a software engineer
today and make it into these Top Gear
companies you have a solid chance of
making seven figures by the time you're
in your 50s seeing this it's no wonder
why so many people are choosing to major
in computer science or stem in general
but this back the question why are
software Engineers paid so much in the
first place
this might be hard to believe but
there's actually a massive shortage when
it comes to software developers in fact
as of 2019 there were 1 million
unfulfilled I.T jobs in the US at first
glance this probably makes no sense
nowadays there's such a massive emphasis
on understanding code even if you're not
pursuing software engineering I mean
even Elementary schoolers are being
taught coding and as you go into middle
school and high school there's dozens of
coding classes that are usually filled
to the brim and as for college if you're
getting any sort of stem degree or even
a business degree at this point it's
basically impossible to graduate without
taking at least one or two coding
classes and all of that is just within
Academia itself outside Academia we have
hundreds of boot camps and courses on
skillshare and udemy not to mention it
the tens of thousands of free videos and
articles available on YouTube and Google
also it's not like the average person is
ignorant to coding either like they were
back in the 1980s virtually everyone
understands how important computer
science is to the modern world and how
lucrative a CS career could be
considering all this you would think
that there's an oversupply of developers
yet this is not the case so what's
creating this disparity between how many
people learn coding and how many people
actually get a job in coding well at the
root of it there can only be two
explanations for this it's either the
employer's fault or the employee's fault
maybe the employers are being too picky
or expecting too much but when you look
at the data this is simply not the case
most tech companies have actually been
lowering their standards like dropping
degree requirements now you can argue
all you want that these tech companies
don't prefer college graduates but
that's besides the point this video
isn't about whether college is worth it
the point is that these tech companies
are objectively making it easier to get
a job with them some research from India
indeed it further confirms this eighty
percent of U.S tech managers have
selected candidates that graduated from
a coding boot camp program and at 99.8
percent of them are willing to hire
similar candidates again so if anything
employers are desperate and this is
extremely evident in their highly
generous compensation packages but if
the shore digit isn't caused by
employers that means that it must be
caused by employees and that's exactly
what's happening the coding industry as
a whole has a massive return problem
developers come in it they stay for a
few years and then they leave the
average tenure at all of the top
companies is literally at Max two years
now of course tenure is cured by new
hires but it's not like turnover would
be that much better anyway I mean High
turnover at these companies is not a
secret we have a full video about this
phenomenon if you're interested but at
the Crux of it more times than not
coders just to get burnt out this is
simply worse and by the fact that a
substantial number of developers don't
like the code to begin with the only
reason they pursued a CS job is because
their parents told them or because the
career made sense to them objectively
from a money or Prestige perspective but
when it comes to the job itself they're
not actually that excited after all you
just sit in front of a computer for
eight hours a day and browse through a
stack Overflow even for the people who
like coding it they usually don't like
the coding they have to do at Facebook
and Google it's not like they're
building the next Instagram or YouTube
more times than not they're banging
their heads on the wall trying to refine
a data sorting algorithm or fixing
menial bugs and after 40 years they
don't really have much to show for any
of it what are they gonna say I made the
Facebook experience indistinguishably
better now this isn't to say that all
software engineering jobs are bad the
type of coding jobs that people actually
like are found at startups where they
can actually play an active role in the
final product and people are usually
more than willing to take a pitch to do
something that they feel is more
meaningful and to minimize this
phenomenon fan companies are usually
forced to pay insane salaries
not only are tech companies trying to
attract and retain developers during a
programmer shortage but they also have
tons of money to throw around this is
thanks to the insane margins that are
unique to the tech industry Facebook has
net margins between 25 and 30 percent
Google also has net margins between 25
and 30 percent meanwhile microsoft.net
March ends up nearly 40 percent with
such margins these companies can raise
salaries faster than any other industry
take fast food for example there's a
massive shortage when it comes to fast
food workers as well but due to the
limited margins in this industry
salaries can't go up all that much even
Starbucks with their six dollar coffees
only profit 10 to 15 percent not only do
tech companies have far higher margins
but they also have far fewer employees
meaning that their profit per employee
is through the roof Google's profit per
employee is 297 000 Apple's profit per
employee is 390 thousand dollars and
Facebook's profit per employee is nearly
half a million dollars the median salary
at Facebook is currently 292 thousand
dollars this means that they could
literally increase the pay of all of
their employees by four hundred thousand
dollars and it still have a hundred
thousand dollars worth of profit left to
spare in other words they could afford
to pay entry-level developers six
hundred thousand dollars if they wanted
to if we do this same math for Starbucks
though it simply doesn't work out before
Starbucks drastically reduced their
Workforce due to the pandemic their
employee counts to the 350 000 and on
good years they profit as much as six
billion dollars this however only works
out to a profit per employee of a little
over seventeen thousand dollars per year
this means that Starbucks could only
increase pay by nine dollars per hour
before having to charge like ten dollars
per cup of coffee and this is why we
don't hear about Starbucks Baristas
being page six figures due to the fast
food shortage but we do hear about
software Engineers being paid seven
figures due to the developer shortage
also that's just half the story
something else to note is that the vast
majority of the high compensations from
these tech companies are stock-based
compensation if we take a closer look at
Facebook's seven figure salary we'll see
that only about 400 000 of the 1.6
million dollars is actually offered in
cash the other 1.2 million dollars is
offered in stock not only is stock
compensation grid for employees given
that they're investing hundreds of
thousands if not Millions into the
fastest growing companies in the world
but it's also great for companies
because it's almost free here's the
thing it's not like these companies go
on to the stock market and buy these
shares at the market price instead what
they do is dilute existing shareholders
to issue new stock to employees and it
turns out that this is extraordinarily
cheap because it doesn't come from their
bottom line it comes from their market
cap for example let's say Facebook
wanted to increase their salaries by a
hundred thousand dollars to attract more
Talent if they increase the salaries of
all 72 000 employees by a hundred
thousand this would cost them a 7.2
billion dollars per year this is quite
an amount but Facebook could comfortably
afford it with their 40 billion dollar
net margin it would cost them about 18
of their profits if they offered the
hundred thousand dollars in the form of
stock though the cost would be relative
to their 393 billion dollar market cap
and 7.2 billion dollars would only cost
1.8 dilution and that's with their stock
falling off a cliff at their Peak market
cap of 1 trillion dollars this extra
compensation would have only cost a 0.66
dilution not to mention employees are
usually restricted from selling stock
compensation for a few years so this
dilution won't even hit the market for
years this is why companies that love
stock compensation that improve employee
loyalty employees make a lot of money
companies can hand out a stupid amount
and it doesn't cost them much the one
caveat to this though is that your
company has to be growing at a rate at
which this dilution would be
inconsequential so stagnant companies
like a t or Cisco or Intel can't
leverage this all that much but the fan
companies well they go to town
at the end of the day the reasoning
behind insane software engineering
salaries it isn't rocket science there's
a shortage of talented software
Engineers because talented developers
don't like to hang out at big companies
and do menial work they far prefer to
invent or build something themselves so
these companies are having to one-up
each other in terms of pay to retain
their developers and with insane profit
per employee and access to easy stock
compensation when these companies try to
outdo each other salaries basically
become a game score instead of money the
funny thing is that these companies
still have an insane amount of Headroom
honestly between sacrificing profits and
dilution I think Facebook could even
afford to pay median salaries of a
million dollars per year now I'm not
saying that they should or that they
will but they could do it automatically
so if you're looking for a
straightforward way to make a stupid
amount of money CS is definitely the way
to go but be warned that the work is not
only difficult but rather monotonous and
oftentimes unfulfilling do you think
coders are overpaid comment that down
below also drop a like if you wish you
were paid this much and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
all right